let's talk about Alec Baldwin so uh
we're we're going to revisit the crowded
stuff obviously because we have 50
billion super chats about it and I just
want to let everyone know that YouTube
YouTube deletes the super chats after a
certain amount of money so we can only
go back to like there's a bunch but I'll
read them and um the current poll says
who is Right Candace I'm sorry who's
right Crowder or DW 74 say Crowder 26a
daily wire but let's talk about Alec
Baldwin we have this story from Vanity
Fair let me just say at the start of
this segment ladies and gentlemen
I believe I called it and I had people
telling me I was crazy and telling me I
was wrong he's being charged with inval
he's going to be charged with
involuntary manslaughter so is the
armorer another guy this isn't director
I think took a plea bargain plea deal
for negligent uh discharge of a firearm
but let me tell you why I said I called
it there's a very important part in uh
in this story
that I will pull up right here
Vanity Fair says in addition to the
bullet that killed Hutchins well I'm
sorry let me slow down Alec Baldwin as
you know about a year ago was on the set
of a movie called rust he was using a
real gun in the filming aimed it at the
cinematographer during filming pulled
the trip pulled the hammer back pull the
trigger shooting her in the chest
penetrating her body and hitting another
guy in the shoulder
everybody was arguing whether it was an
accident how could the bullet have
gotten the gun I made the argument that
we had learned
Alec Baldwin was in a dispute I should
say the the execs of the movie
production the higher-ups which include
Doug Baldwin were in dispute with the
crew the crew was threatening to walk
offset there was animosity Alec Baldwin
said he was friends with her then he
said they weren't friends they didn't
know each other he had a dinner with her
sounded like they were friends or was it
negotiations he also said in an
interview that she was very forceful I
can't remember the word he used and she
kept telling him to do things over and
over again it sounded like he was
venting frustrations about Helena about
Helena oh I didn't know that right and
so I said that sounds to me like motive
motive what is it your crew is
threatening to walk offset costing you
money and Helena Hutchins was doing what
cinematographers aren't supposed to do
giving you direction that he seemed
annoyed by my personal opinion but it's
something he expressed opportunity he
had a gun a real gun that was supposed
to be pointed not at a human being this
is against the rules in any movie Set
you never point a gun at a person no
matter what well against the rules ever
always in shooting unless you're
intending to destroy it right and
hunting everything lied and said he
never pulled the trigger just went off
that's impossible it was a single action
revolver Hammer has to be pulled back
trigger has to be pulled get this
Vanity Fair reports in addition to the
bullet that killed Hutchins
investigators found five additional live
rounds of ammunition mingled among the
movie's props and costumes two loose 45
caliber bolts were discovered on top of
a prop cart a third was in a bandolier
worn by Jensen Ackles a fourth was in a
gun belt worn by Baldwin and a fifth was
found in a box of dummy ammo entirely
possible with Gutierrez raised
fingerprints on it they say it's about
someone mistake mistook the live ammo
that was lying around for dummies put
him in the Box Hannah Gutierrez read
pulled the ammo dummy rounds out of the
box didn't realize loaded the gun and
that's what happened entirely possible
but when you factor all these things
together Alec Baldwin had live ammo on
his belt had the gun pointed it at her
and shot and killed her I don't
understand how anybody would argue that
it's more likely it was an accident when
it's like
he was mad at her because the crew
walk-offs potentially
he pointed the gun at her
he shot her and he had live ammo on his
person
so it's like if we were going to ask
someone Occam's razor in the absence of
evidence the solution that makes the
least amount of assumptions tends to be
the correct one how did the gun how did
the bullets get in the gun well you see
what happened was somebody was doing
target practice with the gun and they
left bullets outside one day a crew
member was cleaning up the bullets and
didn't realize there were lives they put
them back in the Box the box was in
place in the cabinet Hannah goodyears
we're not realizing this grab the box
opened it up pulled the bolt out put him
in the gun handed it to the A.D who
didn't check it and then hand it to Alec
Baldwin who didn't check it and then it
went off on accident or Alec Baldwin
didn't like the lady took a bullet from
his own belt that had bullets in it and
shot her which one is the conspiracy
theory and which one is The Simple
Solution sorry man I just he had a
bullet on his belt okay that's that
there were live bullets found all over
the place or like five of them makes me
gives me some reasonable doubt that
maybe he didn't know what was he wasn't
the one that was Ring leading this that
someone went in there and also I do
agree that he didn't like Helena
Hutchins I felt like she was probably
playing the alpha role and he felt
emasculated he's like I'm supposed to
but you should treat him like an actor
you're doing what I say get this done
we're doing the shot he's like I'm I'm
the producer I'm in charge so he was
like Bang Bang You're Dead like a
potential child a boy bang Bang Yeah
like playing Cowboys and Indians when he
was a little single Bank Yeah Bang and
he's like just fantasizing about killing
her and and it turned out that someone
had loaded his gun yeah I may want to be
clear he's not being tried for murder
he's being tried for manslaughter so
they they have felt that after examining
the evidence that he did this by
accident and what you're alleging is
that maybe it wasn't so much of an
accident and he actually didn't like her
I can't get over the fact that he
pointed the gun out of human beings it's
so important to say this is not a rule
on set this is a rule always and maybe
in New York City where people don't know
anything about guns he knows things a
thing or two about guns he's been in
plenty of movies it's I mean it doesn't
really nothing no I cannot go over the
fact that he did not know that you
should never under any circumstances
unless you are actually actively trying
to kill a human that walked in you know
broke into your homes attacking your
children do you ever point a gun whether
it is loaded or completely empty at a
human being ever or literally if you're
walking through the forest and you're
about to go on a hunt you never ever not
even in joke and just ever are supposed
to even put that you're supposed to keep
it down at all times right yeah
that is just a known rule I even Point
imaginary guns down when I'm pretending
to be a guy with a gun yeah you're gonna
do that there's just no way that he
didn't know that but look what the media
said like the the media ran to his
defense they were they were saying that
is the media right they came out and
they're like there's a horrible tragic
accident and they didn't bother asking
any questions they didn't bother
investigating and if we had a fair media
from the get-go the first thing that
should have happened is there was
fighting on the set Alec Baldwin was
unhappy extremely frustrated he is known
for having a temper he's crazy
people screaming his own daughter causes
like a fat pig and like he's crazy this
man is obviously unhinged he's
completely and utterly unhinged there's
no question but it doesn't matter
actually in Hollywood if you're on
hinged the better right Chrissy Teigen
people have told you a thousand times
that they are mentally unstable angry
people and yet the media goes ah he's
funny let's put him in sentence
they prop them up all the time
especially the more crazier that they
are the more the media loves them which
is uh actually a perfect representation
he was also very outspoken against gun
rights activists and now here he is in
this particular situation now I don't
know what happened here we're gonna you
know a lot of people are speculating
let's see what's going to happen through
this court case uh you know obviously if
this happened to a random Joe schmoe
there would have been charges a lot
quicker the fact that there wasn't
charges and the fact that there was so
long so much time in between this is you
know a little fishy but let's see what
happens in the court of law let's see
what happens with the evidence let's see
uh who you know changed their story who
try to cover something up because
there's multiple stories there's
multiple things we don't know what
happened let's wait and see is that are
there more charges or is this the only
charge there's two charges the jury can
choose from one is five years in prison
mandatory and I think he gets it this
out he should get it they say the first
charge is simple involuntary
manslaughter for this to be proved there
must be underlying negligence under New
Mexico law involuntary manslaughter is a
fourth degree felony punishable by up to
18 months in jail in a five thousand
dollar fine it includes the misdemeanor
charge of negligent use of a firearm
seems like a slap on the wrist the other
charge is involuntary manslaughter in
the commission of a lawful act this
charge requires proof that there was
more than simple negligence involved in
the death it's also a fourth degree
felony punishable bat to 18 months in
jail in a five thousand dollar fine
however
this charge includes a firearm
enhancement or added mandatory penalty
because a firearm was involved the
firearm enhancement makes the crime
punishable by a mandatory five years in
jail based on the official narrative
Alec Baldwin should get the mandatory
minimum I'm not a fan of mandatory
minimum minimums and I don't think
Justice will be served necessarily by
sending Alec Baldwin to prison for five
years but based on the laws it stands
I'll tell you why I think you should go
to jail for five years
negligence he was running the show he
was the producer they were using the gun
from the movie to shoot real bullets
they knew there were negligent
discharges on set that is
that that that says to me
that they say it requires more than
simple and negligence simple negligence
in my opinion and maybe it's a legal
term so maybe I'm wrong but my opinion
on this is if someone unbeknownst to
Alec Baldwin was using live bullets I'd
say look Alec he should have had
um he should have known where that gun
was at all time at times someone should
have been charged so maybe it's it's not
his fault that you know this happened
but he knew there were negligent
discharges now it's not just simple
negligence now it's him being like
there's something more there you mean
that and I think you're you're saying
that prior to that negligent discharge
there were there were previous negligent
discharges on that so he knew that there
were some mistakes happening and you
would think that after the first mistake
and you go oh great nobody died you
would go let's make sure that we button
this up as I am the producer of this I
need to button this up and again I can't
I just cannot say a thousand times over
if you're trying to present the case for
the prosecution here you're just going
to say how many times has Alex been in a
movie where there have been guns fired
he knows this protocol he knows that you
do not Point aegon whether it's loaded
or not add another human being not only
pointing would be negligent by the way
if he had hit her and it was a fake
round he would be negligent forget I
mean pointing it is you just you just
don't pull the trigger and point it and
then pull the trigger and the last thing
I want to say is that I think that in
terms of the publicity surrounding this
if he had instantly come out and said
this is we are so we feel so horrified
we are so sorry I I'm just devastated by
this I'm just going away forever like he
was he has acted the part of such
arrogance right anytime anybody asked a
question he was angry how dare you I'm
Alec Baldwin like the way that he has
acted after this as if he's done nothing
wrong I mean the first thing that his
the statement he rushes to make after
these charges is total and complete
miscarriage of Justice it is this is
this pompous nature that is that that is
really for me the nail in the coffin and
if I'm on that jury I am moving to
convict this is this is why I think
honestly I don't know if I would but let
me let me say this the reason I say the
five years in prison just to elaborate
he knew there were negligent discharges
now you can argue well but it was simple
negligence that he didn't correct that
mistake that he didn't lock things down
that's what negligence is yes then he
picked the gun up pointed at her and
pulled the trigger right so you want to
talk about simple and negligence it
would be the the the the the the
producer on set not Alec Baldwin who
knew there were discharges and did
nothing to correct that problem he's
responsible oh he got he pleaded he took
a plea bargain for a negligent
destructive weapon Alec Baldwin knew
there were that was live ammo on set had
live on his person decided to take the
gun knowing this pointed at a woman and
pulled the trigger now come on I would
actually argue murder like passion
homicide lower degree we don't have it
right so at the very least you have to
move to convict on the charges and I
can't see how a jury outside of being an
Alec Baldwin fan does not actually move
to convict him actually I'll I'm gonna
change my what I just said I want to
clarify I think you're right if I was in
the jury and they said you know
mandatory five years in jail I might
nullify that but agree with him being
charged I don't like mandatory minimums
I don't think Justice is served by
sending them to prison for five years
like a year like five years is not going
to change what happened it's not going
to change Alec Baldwin I think it would
change Alec Baldwin well you're right it
would change him I just don't think it
would actually like he's a very angry
erratic unstable man and I think some
time alone in a cell with another big
guy
a nice prison I I think that it's yeah
it's a long enough time that it could
change but a lot of celebrities are just
totally out of touch a lot of them are
ego made a lot of them are just
sociopaths and as soon as this happened
he tried to of course uh put blame on
anyone else but him the first thing he
said is quote someone is responsible but
I know it is not me yeah that's a
horrible thing
that's somebody's mother I mean think
about this it's horrible the emotional
trauma of this guy basically being like
I don't know it's going to prison but we
know it ain't me exactly and then and
then and talking about this he he kind
of alluded that he's the second victim
here out of all of this especially with
some of the statements that he was
making afterwards which is absolutely
just delusional which shows you this
kind of out of touch reality perspective
that a lot of these very powerful people
that are that are empowered by this CD I
would even say satanic entertainment
industry the people that prop up are
some of the worst human beings on the
face of this Earth and sometimes they do
deserve a big reality check-in and I
think this is maybe but they're so far
in the weeds maybe could provide that
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time